[Music]
you watch the debate last night huh and
who didn't watch it
[Applause]
was that just as many people clap hook
times I probably Dancing with the Stars
or some crap like that that's not crap
oh I'm sorry
yeah people still talking about last
night's debate it was a debate for
undecided voters people who are still
undecided yeah after 44 years of this
campaign they still haven't made up
their minds I don't if you saw at the
beginning Jeremy the college kid who
asked the first question at last night's
debate now says he is no longer
undecided now when when asked to
elaborate he said I am definitely moving
to Canada there was some good news
though for Jeremy last night during the
debate Mitt Romney did you see this MIT
Romney offered him a job right there on
TV yeah offered him a job
Jeremy starts his a new job in China
next Tuesday
[Applause]
they
during the debate one audience member
asked how Mitt Romney was different than
President Bush yeah and President Bush
said that's obvious I would never do
anything to hurt Big Bird
never that's his hero last night Mitt
Romney said when he was looking to hire
a female he would browse through binders
full of women yeah Romney said he got
the idea from Tom Cruise
[Music]
one of the voters in the audience last
night who says he's still undecided was
an african-american male yeah there was
a awkward moment when President Obama
said bro seriously you know they keep
coming out with these little facts his
little fun facts that you need polls and
new research finds that Obama supporters
tend to eat at Red Lobster I'm not
making this up I wish oh yeah they tend
to eat a red lobster while Romney
supporters tend to eat at the Olive
Garden yeah when he heard this chris
Christie endorsed both candidates you
know Larry King he's gonna moderate
night bait
oh I thought you asked if I knew Larry
King and I was gonna say yes I do
next week Larry King time for this big
for you just move on let's move on next
week Larry King will moderate a debate
between third party candidates yeah this
is the first debate Larry's moderated
since the one between Cain and Abel he's
an old gentleman
is an old old gentleman
but enough about the politics New York
man has had 90 surgeries 90 surgeries so
he can look like a human Ken doll yeah I
hate to break it to him but you only
have to have one surgery
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes it's called a smoothening
that sounds like a really terrible
horror movie anyone gonna have the
smoothness movie name honey booboo and
her mother did you know this they spent
the last several days in Los Angeles
honey booboo and her mom I'm not telling
you as a joke I'm just telling you why
your local grocery store ran out of
Cheetos
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
smoothening uh we should try and sell
back to something